الان
الجثث في الشوارع كانوا يعتلون على احد
العربيات كما
تشاهدون تم
استهدافهم وهم في طريقهم الى مراكز
الايواء الكم هذا
[تصفيق]
الكم وين عرب مجازر بتصير بكفي عالم حرام
عليكم يا عرب ايش في ايش في انقذونا يا
عرب من العدو الصاين والمجرم طلع الشهداء
خصورهم طلع
الشهداء شوف الشهداء طلع يا عالم شوف
الشهداء مش حرام هذا عدو ظالم كما تشاهدون
هذه الجثث الان في الطرق
شع
يا الله كما تشاهدون هذه الجثث في
الطرق والان تتعرف احد المواطنين
عليها مجزره كبيره في هذه المنطقه كما
تشاهدون الج الان متواجد في الطرق في
منطقه معسكر جباليه هذا الطفل ملقى على
الارض هذه الجسه تعود لعائله اللو كما
تشاهدون تحلل بعض من
اجسادها ايضا هنا نجد بعض الجثث المتحلله
الساده الان انتشال احد الجثامين من هذه
الطرق كما
تشاهدون شاهدوا ايضا نجد هنا في حافه
الطرق ايضا هنا يوجد شهيد دخلت اليات
الاحتلال في هذه المنطقه كما تشاهدون اثر
تقدم الاليات والاستهداف في هذه المنطقه
نرصد لكم هذا المشهد من قلب معسكر من قلب
مدينه الشيخ
زايد كما
تشاهدون وايضا نشاهد هنا الجثث ما زالت
ملقاه على الارض كما تشاهدون هذا المشهد
يا الله الله هذه الجثث ما زالت ملقاه على
الارض كما تشاهدون شايف في كمان
غ ايضا هذه الجثه في احد الطرق وهم
مواطنين نازحين وهي كمان
شهيد الشهيد الشهدا يا ولد الشهداء اطفال
طالع على
الاطفال هذا هذا طفل طفل هذا طفل حبيبي
هذا طفل حبيب الله المجرمين
اليهود ادخل الى هذا
المركز يوجد احد الجثث داخل هذا المبنى
كما تشاهدون الان هذه ال هذا استشهد
الشهيد الله يرحمه موسى الشنباري واحنا في
المدرسه تحت قنصو قناص من
الاندونيسي